me let me play the video just to make  sure everybody understands we're gonna  we're booting it up here we got Twitter  loading up here we go this week we  launched an initiative alongside  companies and non-profits to help  improve research and understanding of  how a person's online experiences are  curated by automated processes that's  not so bad right this will also be  important in understanding more about  Miss and disinformation online the  challenge that we must As Leaders  address  sadly I think it's easy to dismiss this  problem as one in the margins I can  certainly understand the desire to leave  it to someone else  As Leaders we're rightly concerned that  even the most light touch approaches to  disinformation could be misinterpreted  as being hostile to the values of free  speech that we value so highly see she  says we value Free Speech why is  everybody ragging on this